heute einfach mal sagen schluss mit der
ideologie in der politik wir haben in
deutschland ein problem und das ist dass
viele politische maßnahmen ganz
unterschiedlichen bereichen ideologisch
motiviert und begründet sind das
betrifft zb die energiewende wo
deutschland als einziges land der welt
aussteigen gleichzeitig aus fossilen
energieträgern und aus der atomkraft und
sowohl die merkel regierung als auch
jetzt die ampel stellt sich hin
verbreitet dass noch stolz dass die
ganze welt unser folgen würde ihn
verfolgt uns niemand warum war der
deutsche sonderweg ein holzweg ist in
dem fall um vier sind wieder mal auf dem
holzweg an der stelle das ist eine
simulation unwürdig dass wir abhängig
sind von stromimporten zum beispiel oder
von putins russen gas das darf nicht
sein das betrifft aber auch die
migrationspolitik wenn ich jetzt höre
dass innenministerin nancy faeser eine
koalition der willigen schmieden will
mit deutschland als vorbild deutschland
geht wieder mutig voran will möglichst
offenbar migranten im ausland der mann
hat ja fast den eindruck noch an werben
obwohl wir nicht mal die probleme die
mit der flüchtlingskrise 2015 folgende
gekommen sind tatsächlich schlüssig
bewältigt haben da fährt an doch nichts
mehr zu ein da will uns das ausland
offensichtlich auch nicht folgen weil
wir hier sozusagen der geisterfahrer
sind an der stelle und so geht s so geht
es weiter militante demonstranten die
krankenwagen blockieren hier in berlin
menschen die sich auf die straße kleben
und glauben sie würden damit unser essen
retten das ist ja man soll das nicht
pathologisiert aber das ist ja näher
nahe einer psychose denn an einer
politischen programmatik irgendwie
orientiert und dafür gibt es dann sogar
noch schützenhilfe zum front zum
beispiel grünen-chefin ricarda lang die
auch noch sagt sie hat auch verständnis
dafür dass ist dieses untergangs gerede
wenn wir nicht in drei jahren irgendwie
aufhören unser altglas mit dem auto zum
super mal zum zum also zum
altglascontainer wegzufahren geht die
welt unter so das ist doch alles quatsch
wir brauchen endlich wieder eine
realpolitik eine politik die vernünftig
ist und die sich orientiert tatsächlich
an dem was die breite der gesellschaft
braucht und da gibt es ja genug zu zu
besprechen auch beispielsweise
wohneigentum ist für die mittelschicht
sehr schwer noch zu erreichen die die eu
und energie die preise der teuer schock
das sind alles themen
ja also muss ich sagen tolles medley
herr geißler was sie da gemacht haben
durch alle politikbereiche und ich würde
sagen die neue realpolitik ist man
fortschritt wagen wir haben von angela
merkel in ganz ganz nah verkrustetes
verstaubtes land übernommen was sind
vielen bereichen modernisierungsbedarf
hat sei es in der energiepolitik wir
müssen raus aus der kohleverstromung wir
müssen auch raus aus dem atomstrom oder
folgen uns viele europäische länder
vielleicht frankreich in diesem fall
aber viele andere länder die das auch
kritisch sehen wir haben die zwar die
höchsten strompreise und wenn sie sagen
die sind abhängig vom russen gas dann
ist das so dass russland selbst zu
zeiten des kalten krieges immer
pünktlich seine energie fehllieferungen
abgeliefert hat und das was vertraglich
vereinbart war geliefert hat natürlich
müssen wir diversifizieren da bin ich
mit ihm völlig einig müssen energie aus
mehr quellen kaufen und es wäre schön
wenn wir auf unter 50 modellen kommen
würden mit den russischen gaslieferungen
aber die russischen gaslieferungen
kommen und auf die kann man sich
verlassen und dafür brauchen wir auch
neuestem zwei
migrationspolitik sie haben es
angesprochen und die frau waren sie 81
von auch fachkräftemangel ja es will ja
keiner im krankenhaus arbeiten ich habe
mehrere termine mit den ihk es in
mecklenburg vorpommern gehabt überall
werden fachkräfte gesucht wir brauchen
also eine unbürokratische anwerbung von
fachkräften die zu uns kommen bei den
auch die qualifikationen anerkannt
werden und wir ohne die unsere
wirtschaft gar nicht mehr in gang halten
können und auch das war warum nicht
unser ja sie reden von angela merkel die
ein verstaubtes land hinterlassen hat
wenn ich mich recht entsinne mag sein
dass ich falsch liege hat die spd in den
letzten 16 jahren angela merkel an zwölf
jahren mitregiert in zwölf jahren
mitregiert also seit 2005 zwölf jahre
lang war die spd mit dabei unterbrochen
2009 bis 2013 von einer schwarz gelben
koalition das heißt sie waren ja immer
mit dabei das heißt die spd hat dieses
land ja mit eingestaubt muss man
wirklich so sagen und beim thema energie
sich als kleinerer koalitionspartner
auch nicht immer durchsetzen im sozialen
dingen haben wir das getan wir haben
familien gelten eingeführt dann im
mindestlohn eingeführt aldinger waren
der spd problem programmatik aber es
wird hat das zur verstärkung des landes
mit beigetragen vielleicht erst aber
einmal ganz kurz zum thema ich das sagen
darf beim thema energie wundert mich
immer die argumentation vor allem von
spd politikern aber auch von grünen
politikern die gar nicht sehen wollen in
welches drama wir hinein laufen wir
sollen den anteil der stromerzeugung
noch mal fast um 50 prozent erhöhen von
560 terawattstunden pro jahr auf 730
ungefähren im jahr 2013 von neun jahren
gleichzeitig berauben wir uns ungefähr
50 prozent dessen was wir an
stromerzeugung haben konventionelle
kohle was sinnvoll ist und kernkraft das
heißt wenn wir das reduzieren brauchen
wir eigentlich 100 prozent wir brauchen
200 prozent mehr
kapazität für stromerzeugung wie soll
das eigentlich in neun jahren
funktionieren und der hinweis deswegen
steigen aus der kernkraft aus einmal
richtig ist der ist das ist ja kein
argument also wir gehen ja sehenden
auges in ein echtes drama rein wollen
wir zum dritten mal entscheiden das
thema kernkraft jetzt drin bleiben also
der lösungsvorschlag wir haben ein
lösungsvorschlag der kabel ist der
lösungsvorschlag der ampel ist es jetzt
eine planungs beschleunigung machen um
durch diesen ausbau der netze der
erneuerbaren energien photovoltaik
windkraft und so weiter auch kraftvoll
vorantreiben zu können und wir brauchen
gas als brückentechnologie und brauchen
dafür auch die leitungs infrastruktur
und darum ist auch wichtig 19 21 netz
geht aber noch zum 2 ist das wo es auch
protest gibt dass das noch nicht so ganz
klimaneutral ist trotz noch mal die
frage können technologien können sie
versprechen dass
die ampel ist schafft die erzeugung die
nötig ist also das ganze wird 200
prozent zu steigern bis 2030 versprechen
kann ich das jetzt natürlich nicht an
diesem kurs werden sich einfach das zu
tun aber wir werden alles dafür tun dass
es so schnell unbürokratisch wie möglich
von ihrer lehrerin freuen wenn sie wenn
sie nicht weiß ob sie sich um kriegt und
zu welchem preis oder ich muss langsam
nur noch lachen hier ehrlich gesagt das
ist hier ist es wissen wieso die die wie
es wirklich in der politik funktioniert
da wird nämlich immer viel geredet und
viel geplant und viele
planungsvorschläge gemacht und vorschlag
des vorschlags des vorschlags und es
passiert einfach viel zu wenig natürlich
ist das toll aus der atomkraft
auszusteigen und da bin ich auch eine
befürworterin aber doch erst wenn wir im
plan haben wie es danach weitergeht wie
sollen wir das der machen und spätestens
jetzt merkte dass auch der letzte bürger
war jetzt ist das geweine plötzlich groß
über die hohen strompreise herzlichen
glückwunsch das ist politisch gemacht
und wirtschaftlich leider überhaupt
nicht mehr stemmbar und nicht umsonst
stand jetzt im wall street journal dass
deutschland die dümmste
strompolitik aller zeiten hat und das
kann ich nur so unterschreiben es ist
ehrenwert zu sagen wir wollen das klima
schützen aber es muss auch machbar sein
atomkraft ist ja also noch
funktionierende atomkraftwerke wie wir
es ja zum jahreswechsel gemacht vom netz
zu nehmen drei in einer energiekrise zum
einen angesichts der höchsten
strompreise der welt und die ja
sozusagen co2 neutral laufen das halte
ich tatsächlich wirklich für pure
ideologie das war doch ein fehler das
war und ist ein pro kilowattstunde
kosten der produktion wenn wir die
lagerung und den betrieb mit einrechnen
die vom steuerzahler finanziert würde
dann eine in erneuerbare energie
kilowattstunde 710 kosten ist deutlicher
preisunterschied ja
noch heute entscheiden müssten glaube
ich würden wir alle sagen wir steigen
erst aus der kohle auszusteigen dann aus
der atomkraft auch die reihenfolge war
falsch aber es muss auch mal sagen
damals hat man in deutschland das waren
eine mehrheit über mehrere jahrzehnte
mac stabil etwa drei viertel der
bevölkerung die ein atomausstieg wollten
ein und er haben jetzt machen sie sich
zu leicht nein die schwarz gelbe
koalition hat im herbst 2010 den
atomausstieg von rot-grün rückgängig
gemacht und hat gesagt ja
dann um einfach wirklich die geschichte
so zu erzählen wie sie ist gab es ein
tsunami über 10.000 kilometer entfernt
und auf grund der tsunami angst die man
offenbar auch in deutschland hat hat man
gesagt jetzt steigen wir hieraus gab
überhaupt keinen grund hier auszusteigen
ich werde die unter schwarz-gelb ich
werde den ausstieg nicht rechtfertigen
weil ich wie gesagt ich halte die
reihenfolge für falsch werden erst raus
aus der kohle sollen und dann irgendwann
aus der aus der atomkraft aber es war
eine breite gesellschaftliche mehrheit
über viele jahrzehnte hinweg spätestens
seit den 80er jahren seit dem atom
unglück in der ukraine die gewollte dass
wir in deutschland aussteigen und jetzt
merken wir dass es geht nicht so einfach
die preise steigen wir werden strom
importieren wir werden auch strom aus
kernkraftwerken in frankreich
importieren und das wird die neue
realität sein wir sehen uns in
deutschland nicht autark mit strom
versorgen was aber auch kein drama ist
ich glaube wir brauchen insgesamt mehr
europäischen energiemarkt mit vielen
netzen wenn wir können solarstrom sehr
günstig irgendwo in südspanien
produzieren wir können anderen küstenort
europa sehr günstig strom produzieren
aber der strom muss land einkommen wurde
warum ist das eigentlich kein problem
atomstrom aus frankreich zu importieren
aber eigene natur strom in deutschland
herzustellen
gut wir haben immer in wir mussten immer
strom importieren ja das war immer schon
der fall also es wäre unseren
strombedarf nicht selber decken konnten
und natürlich wäre es schöner wir
müssten diese atomstrom nicht aus
frankreich importieren aber das ist okay
frankreich das ist realität zumindest ja
ob das okay sein name frage
foto kw strom aus braun zum beispiel da
muss man auch sagen das hilft dem klima
nicht da werden wir hätten wir besser
noch auf unseren atomstrom gesetzt in
dem fall ja hat man nicht das gefühl
dass die politik den problem immer
hinterherrennt ja also ich höre ist es
für über viele jahre schon eigentlich
absehbar gewesen das funktioniert nicht
es muss erst immer so zum totalen
zusammenbruch kommen wir so gar nichts
mehr geht bis dann kommt vielleicht
müssen wir überdenken brauchen wir ein
plan b ich finde das eigentlich fatale
also tatsächlich würde man unternehmen
so führen gibt es keine mehr es muss man
mal ganz klar so sagen und wir sind ja
auch nicht ganz ehrlich ist wird ja vom
steuerzahler finanziert wenn ich jetzt
josef heizkostenzuschuss geben wer zahlt
das denn alles das zahlen die
steuerzahler
und jetzt heißt es schon 180 euro sind
zu wenig 270 euro sind zu wenig jetzt
wird gefordert 500 euro heizkosten
errechnet dass man hoch auf die
gesamtbevölkerung das ist doch ein
irrsinn was wir hier machen würden sie
eigentlich die politik gehen ja ich
glaube ich würde wahrscheinlich tot im
straßengraben nach einer woche legen
heute ich habe täglich werden meine zu
aber so ehrlich ist soll ich mehr
unternehmer die politik gehen uns fern
doch gerade unternehmerinnen unternehmer
in der politik das ist nämlich mal ich
verstehe dass sie haben sie wir haben
nicht so furchtbar viel zeit sich diesem
hobby zu widmen vielen unternehmen zu
leiten habe aber eigentlich bräuchten
wir den parlamenten mehr leute mit
unternehmer erfahrungen der beide kommen
aus bayern ihr haar aus der nähe von
münchen möglicherweise nachher gerne
den einen kandidaten als 220 23 was hat
sie eigentlich bewogen in die politik zu
gehen ich bin relativ viel in der welt
unterwegs gewesen auch beruflich habe
ein stockholm gelebt ich habe in tel
aviv gelebt einige länder gesehen war
auch im auslandseinsatz und wenn man
dann wenn man als soldat in afghanistan
in mali ist eine feststellen das telefon
eines mobilfunk netz funktioniert
wesentlich besser im einsatz sein haus
in mecklenburg vorpommern dann ist das
eine sache wo ich sage okay dinge die
kann ich nicht akzeptieren ich möchte
vor allem dass mehr chancen dass wir
wirklich im 21 jahrhundert ankommen ich
habe gesagt ich mein mann ist den ich
kann mich per telefon jetzt ihr scheiden
lassen kann man ja darüber diskutieren
ob man das gut findet aber es geht
das hat einen großen
fehler passieren heirat ich möchte handy
das nicht also das gehört zu den 23
prozent der verwaltung an einem handy
gehen aber ich finde einfach wir müssen
im 21 jahrhundert ankommen und das sind
dinge die mich ärgern und sie sagen
zurecht gewarnt dass wenn sie im
unternehmen wie die bundesrepublik
führen würden es vielleicht pleite wäre
aber ist es doch auch so will ich
irgendwo mobilfunk max aufstellen gibt
es protest ja also sind auch riesig wir
müssen auch sehen dass wir uns diesen
fortschritt implementiert kriegen und
auch schnell implementiert kriegen weil
wir können nicht jeden straßenkilometer
jede leitung jeder mast diskutieren bis
ins unendliche und das fünfmal beklagen
lassen das geht nicht wir müssen jetzt
vorankommen ich habe meinem wahlkreis
den start die hat sich vor 150 jahren
entschieden sie möchten keine eisenbahn
haben weil die eisenbahn gefährlich wäre
die leute die leiden heute noch daran
dass er warf und diese von der
hauptstrecke gewechselt war und herren
wir haben jetzt diskutiert über corona
über was sonst können sie wahrscheinlich
oder werden sie auch sagen wir haben
diskutiert über die frage wie
glaubwürdig ist eigentlich deutsche
politik noch und nach der kurzen pause
da geht es weiter mit zwei wirklich
spannenden themen es geht unter anderem
auch um putin und die ukraine bis gleich